[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vrai que j'ai toujours eu envie de voler
chez fans de science fiction
des fois je vois également sur 10 sont
des navettes spatiales gîtas mais en
fait à la base je suis fille ordinaire
j'ai toujours été si ordinaire à
l'époque très timide mais fusil
tétanisés par la timidité à un compte
est de cette veine à la vie je m'accepte
années que le rapport les personnes qui
ne peuvent pas sortir en présence
d'autres personnes ont fait leur
apparition dont j'étais adolescente
était adolescent
on serait déplacé je vais survolé
simplement c'est sous le choc la
rejoindre sans problème si seulement
j'avais eu des scènes il mourrait pas
écrit en frais en fait pour moi je
serais allé directement presque dans
toutes les situations j'étais confronté
à ça à la poule à la présence des autres
enfants et mon parcours également pollen
de l'ordinaire je rêvais également de
devenir un baiia de la communication là
bas l'agresseur un maya de la
communication voir diriger une
entreprise de communication également
que le domaine a sollicité parce que
j'aime ça communiquer échanger et parler
aux gens
je me rappelle également que j'avais été
vaincu par le plie aux exigences anti
manif ou quand j'avais vu à l ambiance
son agent c'est bon on laisse un peu le
côté et travers ce film d mais je voyais
dans une agence est en train de tirer
cette agence mais pour ça il fallait que
je suivais des études en bourse
plication et que j'aille dans une grande
école de communication mais mes parents
inverse implantation ce pont droits des
fonctionnaires
donc ils ont été meilleurs
c'est berner par l'argent public donc
pour tous qui en veut à son public était
un peu mystique
donc il ne voit pas dans ses fonctions
de communication et à la fin quand
j'allais m'en bat non mais l'issue
d'élections censées conduire tubes à la
fac dans le monde
je peux pas alors parce que c'est ce
qu'ils voyaient pour moi mais moi je
veux le voir en moi et alice sont au
niveau de notre nos visions mais ce sont
les parents et j'ai pas le choix je
détestais les mathématiques mais j'ai dû
faire avec et j'ai dû à une reprise
économique alors que je voudrais
absolument pas sur celles issues et
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai rencontré
des personnes et jeune homme quand moi
qui était passionné de technologie des
thermes et parce qu'à cette époque on
était en 2009
on découvrait la technologie en fait
internet les marais et nous on était un
peu des fous c'est à dire quand vous
organisez des grandes conférences et
abidjan et tout cela en protège en
partie comment la plupart connaissent
ici cassiman à tous un peu les pères
fondateurs de la politique a également
qui a donné le nom à cuneo a et on était
des fous à cette époque est moins que
jamais cette énergie là en fait j'étais
entouré de jeunes jambes qui est aussi
passionné par en commun qui nous
plaisait parce que j'étais passionné
d'internet et de technologie et je me
suis rendu compte qu'à ce moment là la
communication domenech digital et
devenir de plus en plus digital je me
suis dit j'y fais du sport communication
mais peut-être que je peux juin et deux
beaux mouvements inconel dedans mais je
ne savais pas ce moment-là ce
rigoureusement ce que je
mais je me réveille dans les conférences
comme départ quand on est assis par
terre on a les orateurs on et éthiques
on est passionné on sait pas quand leurs
bagages en mai et qui se présente comme
ça dans une ambiance parcs tél
ça c'est que ça que vous présente on a
organisé avec jean patrick et l'italie
sans et des autres la première le
premier parfum presque sans argent mais
d'énergie que chaque exclu à l'autre à
fait remis également moi de me rendre
compte que je pouvais des ailes
peut-être que je pouvais et je me suis
senti un peu galvanisés en fait à part
peut enfin il vraiment je les en
remercie parce que à ce moment là
j'avais invité au bout de la deuxième
année il mettait tout bon sens
économique parce que je voulais pas que
c'est pas du même nom et au nom je me
suis dit c'est ma vie c'est moi qui
connais tu j'ai une bonne ce sont mes
parents mais je dois pouvoir et benzema
et là je les ai inventées et ça va ça se
passait bien
énergie pour ça mais je vivre de sa
passion son nom de l'argent c'est
vraiment pas l'internet pour cette
raison se connecte les sites internet et
où on parle à des gens qui sont à
l'étranger qui partagea la même énergie
que nous mais nous l'argent et à cette
époque j'avais et de l'ue par mes amis
comme c'est bizarre général de
l'organisation et pour moi c'était comme
andy qui arrivent un peu de monde de la
timidité
parce que pouvoir elle ses fruits en
général d'une organisation où tout le
monde compte sur vous et pouvoir régler
monde à chaque fois c'est un exercice
qui m'a sorti au fur et à mesure de ce
set banati le ranger la timidité et au
fur et à mesure que je pouvais être
échangé avec donc personnes issues des
réseaux sociaux communiqué sur cette
organisation qui a bien fait qui démarre
également à l'époque je me suis rendu
compte que toutes les heures les huit
planches que je passais bien sûr un
homme facebook à chaque fois je n'ai pas
d'argent mais je n'aime pas le confiance
on appris chez moi à la maison je me
suis rendu compte des métiers en europe
au fil de leurs échanges je me suis dit
mais la community management mais on est
en 2002 en 2001 je peux en faire un
métier en fait
mais comment j'ai pas suivi l'étudiant
en communication c'est génial je n'ai
aucune formation dans ce domaine tout ce
que j'ai appris que tu l'a appris sur le
tas et on peut mais dit quelques
entreprises
qu'on arrête ma chance point n'est pas
de formation dans ce domaine
lundi sous le tas le pouvoir exercé le
métier de comédien et voilà une
entreprise
aweys que j'aurais aimé ainsi également
maintenir la chance et la première fois
j'ai exercé officiellement tant que
community manager dans une entreprise en
fait c'était inédit
je me suis retrouvé à ma place a fait
et qu'ils aient cru en moi à ce moment
là pour être déjà à cette époque comme
mon petit manageur mais je m'éclatais
j'ai commencé à découvrir un peu au
niveau verne qui me passionnait et quand
j'ai compris que je rencontrais d'autres
personnes je m'habille pas les
conférences je partageais un peu
et les joies de ce métier avec d'autres
jouent simple essaiera également
équipements faire une exception à mesure
j'avais la possibilité de pouvoir
je dormais dans ce métier mais un moment
je me suis dit faut aller plus loin je
pensais que je commençais à trouver un
club en fait je voulais à la pause 12
heures je voulais un peu plus sur play
est dans une équipe dans une agence
c'était un métier c'était uniquement une
agence digitale avec d'autres passionnés
qui l'a même pas sûr de moi dans
lesquels on en ferait une famille
bolloré dans cette agence a choisi 10 à
cette époque comment fait quelques
agences digitales me confierait la
gestion de son entreprise
c'est vrai que j'ai eu la chance de
coincer com community manager et
community manager est différente de
l'évolution de certains managers jeu
mais aussi de voir si j'avais eu les
faits voilà pourquoi pas je serai hague
à l'étranger j'aurais écouté ma chose si
j'avais eu des menaces parce qu'à ce
moment là également j'avais eu les
premiers enfants
peut-être que je serai à lire avec lui à
l'étranger quand tu es ma jambe pour un
pays ont peu évolué dans une agence
digitale mais qui n'avait pas dire et
penser que j'ai tourné et finalement je
rencontre une agence digitale avec son
directeur qui finale en menant également
mal chance de pouvoir les infos que si
justin manager je ne connaissais pas le
monde digital manager à l'époque c'était
une nouveau pour moi mais le fait de
pouvoir passer à un autre
dans ce domaine dans lequel je
m'épanouissais geocities est immense
parce que je démarrais tout ce je
n'avais aucune idée je devais plutôt
démarré sur glace comme ce crash et au
fur et à mesure j'ai commencé à
m'occuper des jeunes gens qui avaient du
talent qui font issus de formations
différentes parce que votre formation
la grève dure en digital et qu'ils ont
appris au fur et à mesure on sait
communiquer cette passion on s'éclate
dans cette agence
je me sentais vraiment à ma place en
fait et c'était vraiment on va dire
comme on le vit le pied mais à ce moment
là également je pense que les
conférences le temps que je passais à
communiquer également avec les étudiants
sur ce métier et tout le prennent
également du temps mais c'était ce que
je voulais faire ce que je voulais faire
depuis le début je me suis trouvé ma
place mais il s'est trouvé un moment où
mon équipe avait besoin de vendre donc
ces jaunes avec lesquels j'ai démarré
les développeurs designers et tous
avaient besoin de moi parce qu'ils
étaient invités à participer au concours
pour hydro est la chance de pouvoir
briller et faire éclater leur talent
avec nos designers développeurs mais
j'ai trouvé que ils n'ont pas eu la
possibilité de pouvoir partir assez pour
vous et moi
vu l'opposition 2
de la boîte à ce moment là tu n'es pas
là permet de pouvoir partir à ce
concours j'ai pas eu la possibilité mois
l'on croit les épées pense que si
j'avais des ailes
je leur ai prouvé père lui trois enfants
qui passent beaucoup je leur ai même je
les aurais même porté sous les ailes à
ce moment là pour elle les parties par
trous qu'il a au respect remis le
pouvoir challenger avant leurs
compétences dans le domaine digital et
je me suis dit mais je suis un diesel je
pense que tu peux aider ces jeunes à
pouvoir s'épanouir
tu as des espaces que depuis le début
tu es parti de zéro pour arriver à
monter une entreprise dans le domaine du
digital mais pourquoi tu ne créerait pas
sa propre entreprise sites allemands
avec tout ce que je savais que comme
l'expérience de plus visible et la
leucémie
je peux essayer je peux essayer d'aider
également ces jeunes à pouvoir fort en
eux à pouvoir montrer qu'ils sont
capables également de pouvoir vivre la
passion c'est vous mais c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire au quotidien
également dans le domaine du globe
puisque je fais également glorieuses
j'essaie au quotidien de pouvoir faire
éclater montrer à la face du monde ces
personnes qui rayonne dans ce domaine et
je pense que la plupart d'entre nous qui
avons la possibilité de pouvoir booster
les autres arbres constante de ne
pouvoir
décidé à aller de l'avant non j'ai cru
que je voudrais pas passer un long j'ai
été j'ai carrément et d'effectifs
je me sentais coincé mais a toujours eu
des personnes qui m'ont permis de
rencontrer le médecin
j'avais des ailes à ses puissantes doit
croire en moi pouvoir crier au métier
dans un pays à mon goût on ne
connaissait pas du tout le community
manager est aujourd'hui plein de jeunes
arrivent à en vivre convenablement
donc je pense que fouquet dans la salle
et vous qui avez des éléments qui
avaient la possibilité de pouvoir
pousser les autres autour de vous vous
devez pouvoir les prendre sur vos haines
et les aider à décoller c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire au quotidien c'est pas
une tâche aisée mais c'est pas seulement
parce que quand je dis je suis folle
j'adore logis j'adore me voir planer au
dessus de mes problèmes je pense
qu'ensemble on peut aider tous ensemble
à pouvoir donc j'aimerais vous avez vous
avez tous dlc que vous êtes là parce que
vous avez puis de taper toujours au delà
elle est toujours là d'une capacité
c'est fou hein tomber cet objectif
merci beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]